[Musique]
bon bah
caroline fourest est devons engager
je crois en tout cas on m'a toujours dit
que je l'étais je sais juste pas faire
autrement parce que moi ça me semblait
difficile de faire une émission sur
l'engagement sans vous recevoir ici
vous connaissez votre surnom j'en ai
plusieurs
alors vous pensez auquel par exemple je
suis le connais pas je suis le pire
qu'on vous ait donné c'était le pire
c'est moi qui est très communément
répandue c'est jeanne d'arc
ok ça ça vient de certains groupes
particuliers mais d'accord je sais pas
on peut y lire plein de choses la jeanne
d'arc vouziers quoi vous je pense que
c'est une contre
c'est une contre appellation dans mon
cas parce que jeanne d'arc ce serait
plutôt celle qui défend l'identité
éternelle et chrétiennes de la france
était plutôt l'opposé ce que je défends
c'est aussi quelqu'un qui va jusqu'au
bout seuls dans l'adversité
quels que soient les joueurs qui se
mettent en face d'elle qui continue qui
peut être aveugle et qui on peut la lire
comme ça c'est ce côté là je prends cela
vous prenez c'est souvent parce que je
vous ai déjà interviewé et à chaque fois
qu on a fait des interviews ensemble
après on me disait mais c'est bizarre
n'est pas dogmatique elle s'est pas
énervé comment ça se fait vous
l'expliquer moussa ses réflexions j'ai
fini par expliquer honnêtement pendant
des années j'ai pas compris
j'ai pas compris comment en étant aussi
calme et en défaisant en défendant des
positions aussi modérée en fait puisque
je défends essentiellement liberté
égalité laïcité c'est pareil c'est pas
super révolutionnaire non plus et donc
je comprenais pas ces procès qu'il
revenait en ondes et qu'on décrivait
comme une pasionaria comme une croisée
agressive et dogmatique agressivité mais
calme et modéré bah c'est la réalité
c'est que c'est ça en fait sauf que j'ai
fini par comprendre qu'une femme qui
défend des convictions sans justement
faillir son refus sans reculer très
franchement qui le dit juste très
franchement en fait pour plein d'hommes
c'est déjà être surexcitée pour des
sommes pour des femmes aussi parfois il
ya des ya beaucoup de femmes qui suivent
le discours gaudi le discours dominant
lui lesieu quelles qualités faut avoir
pour être engagé caroline quand on est
engagé c'est bien d'avoir du second
degré mois sur soi même alors pas quand
on est en train de se battre et comme on
prend des coups de partout là il faut
qu'il faut se défendre avant tout mais
pour garder un équilibre personnel
il faut avoir d'abord des amis super qui
ont beaucoup le sens de l'humour et et
avoir cette distance vis-à-vis de
soi-même parce que ça permet quoi cette
distance vis-à-vis de soi-même
face aux engagements qu on a pris ça
permet de garder la lucidité
ouais moi je crois en fait moi j'aime je
me suis jamais considéré comme un
militant tu me suis
découvert une vocation pour pour le
journalisme puis pour la réalisation
pour le fait j'aime écrire j'aime
raconter j'aime alerter j'ai manqué tu
es aussi je le fais de façon engagée
parce qu'en fait j'ai travaillé très
vite sur des sujets qui sont difficiles
où il y avait beaucoup de coups à
prendre à dire je trouvais dans mes
enquêtes et donc il a fallu ensuite
défendre mon analyse est le fait de
défendre mon analyse m'a mis en position
d'être en combat permanent
mais pour tenir face à ça sans perdre ce
qui est pour moi l'essentiel c'est à
dire essayer de dire des choses justes
le malgré tout ne pas se laisser
emporter ni par la colère ni par même
son personnage ont fait de vous un
personnage public qui génère une
certaine attente et des fois on peut se
faire piéger par ce que s'engager
totalement dans l'ombre par ailleurs on
peut aussi décider de choix aussi qu'on
fait bien sûr mais quand on s'engage à
un moment donné on veut plaire à ses
amis ouais moi j'essaie d'y résister
parce que mon but pour moi c'est plutôt
de lancer des alertes et donc pour
rester lucide et pour essayer de dire
des choses justes sans blesser embarqués
parce qu'on attend de moi j'essaie
d'avoir ces moments de refroidissement
de distance de recul je suis pas tout le
temps dans les médias je me retire de
temps en temps là je me suis fait une
petite cure de trois ans qui m'a fait du
bien
il faut des fois aussi pour s'engager à
mais je pense qu'il faut avoir un
caractère impossible
non non il faut avoir un caractère
d'emmerdeur merdeuse bien sûr que vous
êtes une emmerdeuse
oui bien sûr non je suis pas capable
j'ai je crois que je vais capable de
compromis mais je suis pas capable de
supporter ni la mauvaise foi ni
l'injustice ça ça me proposait une
phrase elle devrait faire écho quelque
part dans un coin de votre tête cette
phrase elle est là globalement dans la
bataille des idées un garçon est un
intellectuel une femme militante blanche
a laissé cette phrase je connais surtout
l'auteur je connais surtout le c'est
marrant c'est votre compagne je savais
plus si c'est en fait on pour ce
tellement souvent la même chose avec
fiammetta qu'on sait plus qu'il a pensé
aux prêts
mais vous avez choisi quelqu'un a une
très bonne référence c'est toujours vrai
ou c'est un peu un peu datés ça
maintenant maintenant c'est toujours
maintenant c'est toujours vrai vraiment
il reste quelques enclaves comme ça la
question des effets groupe ce qui a
changé ce qui est vrai moi quand j'ai
débuté tous les garçons et éditorialiste
et les femmes restées journalistes
reporters etc honnêtement je pense que
la fonction d'éditorialistes aujourd'hui
on l'a on l'a on a réussi à la conquérir
et les plus en plus de femmes qui sont
considérés comme capable de donner leur
opinion et pas simplement d'aller faire
des reportages le nom d'un intellectuel
il reste associé un accord plutôt un
garçon est ce que ça peut être cool
d'être engagé est-ce que c'est forcément
après l'engagement mais il faut pas moi
je crois pas du tout au fait qu'on
s'engage sur un mode sacrificielle ou
malheureux et d'ailleurs il ya des
moments où je les ai sentis et des
moments où j'ai senti que je faisais
passer un petit peu trop la mission que
je pensais devoir remplir pour les
autres avant mon équilibre personnel et
je m'en suis beaucoup méfier c'est aussi
pour ça qu'il ya des moments où je me
suis retiré un peu de débat public parce
que je pense qu'on est on n'est pas bon
quand on se sacrifie pour les autres
c'est marrant ce que vous dites parce
que moi j'ai l'impression que la mission
et vous c'est la meilleure chose ça se
confondait ça s'est jamais confondu chez
vous non pas chez mme pas dans ma tête à
moi mais dans la tête des gens soit
c'est normal parce qu'avais je m'expose
que pour ça j'ai plein d'amis qui me
disent mais pour qu'on ne voit jamais de
marée à la télé etc
je dis mais pas ce que je vais jamais en
télé sauf pour me battre contre
l'extrême droite où les islamistes sinon
je préfère rester chez moi en fait je
suis très bien est-ce qu'il faut
toujours aller trop loin quand on est
engagé en tout cas sur des sujets comme
ça et on va parler du choix des sujets
on vous a vu montrer vos seins sur
facebook on vous a vu imposer sur sky
news
la une de charlie c'est super quand même
un certain quoi je peux montrer sur rue
alors mais je sais des choses dans leur
contexte
il dit comme ça je pense que même moi ça
pourrait me surprendre il ya eu une
campagne pour soutenir une jeune
tunisienne qui a des journées bien sûr
c'est même contre des fondamentalistes
acquerront je pense que c'est un geste
pour montrer s'il y avait le sigle des
personnalités qui par soutien à mina ont
fait les photos topless torse nu et donc
voilà la première précision c'est allé
loin
elle a d'ailleurs par contre montré en
direct quand quand on sort de l'attentât
de charlie hebdo pendant une semaine
vous allez les médias du monde entier
qui vous disent alors c'est quoi leur
prochaine couverture et que quand ils
font leur couverture aussi douce aussi
tendre est aussi courageuse que celle
qu'a fait luz et qu'aucun média
américain anglais de vol à montrer mais
que j'entends dans mon oreillette la
présentatrice de skynews expliqué que
cette couverture est offensante c'était
tout est pardonné un tout est pardonné à
mahomet qui dit tout est pardonné je
suis charlie et qu'on entend dans son
oreillette charlie hebdo a encore fait
une provocation et un crime et a répondu
à l'attentât par conversion chanson je
vous assure que le montrer je discutais
parler légitimité de la chose non il
faut un certain courage quand même pour
montrer sur une antenne enfin il faut se
dire je dépasse le cadre je vais au-delà
de la limite c'est interdit sur cette
antenne
moi je le montre il faut quand même mais
je ne pouvais pas faire autrement je
sais que je dis j'ai été tellement
sidéré parce qu'elle perd ce qu'elle
était en train de raconter
donc effectivement je dis et je le dis
calmement jeudi mais avant de les
condamner à mort une seconde fois vous
voudriez pas montré cette couverture
avec spectateurs qu'il juge par eux
mêmes et au moment où je la montre je
l'entends couper l'antenne elle a créé
l'antenne vous apprendrez près avec
cette dame noire est par contre le
cameraman qui était en face de moi qui
étais le pauvre pour rien d'ailleurs
mais qui était tout seul face à moi
parce que ça se tourner en doute chez
moi j'ai usa / j'avais je mettais pas
énervé depuis le début depuis ce qui
s'était passé le 7 janvier là j'ai crié
et j'ai dit vous les avez tué une
seconde fois continuer à les faire
passer pour des salopards à des gens qui
offensent volontairement les croyants
vous voulez quoi qui les tuent tous ces
sacs il reste aucun envie là j'ai
vraiment crier c'est le caméraman
qu'après il était d'accord avec moi on
va faire un petit bond dans le temps on
retourne en 1972 à l'époque à
apostrophes qui passent à la télévision
la fameuse émission de bernard pivot et
décide de consacrer tout un apostrophe
aux femmes alors ils invitent uniquement
des femmes et un homme qui s'appelle
michelle perrot et face à lui il ya
entre autres
gisèle halimi super on vous dit en
politique
être femme est devenue un argument
publicitaire
avantagerait là bas c'est ce qu'on est
en train de voir mais monsieur merci
quand on est en train de voir ses
chambres et fragile vraiment hot et
j'écoutais je ne prétends pas avoir 48 %
du temps et si de parole bien 48 voulons
renault conserve encore une fois laissez
moi écouter c'est moi dire ce que j'ai à
dire on ne fait que parler écrié
gesticuler vous faites des scènes de
ménages gardez vos n'arrive à dire après
ça mais moi il ya des gens qui m'ont dit
dernère sur des plateaux j'étais face à
des extrémistes et je parlais tout
doucement très calmement car tvo nerfs
en fait quand une femme juste dit
quelque chose qui leur déplaît il ya
encore des hommes qui ont un réflexe
incroyable qui vous qui vous réduisent à
l'hystérie immédiatement c'est ce qu'ils
disent combien de mois on voit aussi
autre chose dans cette archive qui
datent de 72 je rappelle il ya
clairement deux camps il ya clairement
des gens qui sont opposés mais d'abord
sa clope à laisse tranquille ça fait
assez chez elle moi je savais pas c'est
bien mais mais mais surtout si on est
dans la conversation oui on n'est pas
d'accord clairement on est opposé il
c'est pas grave on peut être les uns à
côté des autres et continuer chacun avec
son idée mais on peut cohabiter il n'y a
pas de clash n'y a pas de violence je
viens de voir c'est quand même
l'équivalent d'un début de clash bien
sûr qu'on est allé en fait ce qui se
passe dans notre époque qui est vraiment
pénible c'est qu'il ya ce qui se passe
sur les plateaux télé ressemble de plus
en plus à internet
la violence verbale à laquelle on s'est
habitués tous avec les réseaux sociaux
est en train de déborder dans notre vie
réelle effet que effectivement en nos
conversations sont devenus impossibles
parce que immédiatement on est habitué
désormais à s'insulter et celle des
personnes sur aucun plateau
j'ai une fois eu un mot qui je crois est
assez doux au regard de
la mesquinerie face à laquelle j'étais
qu'elle fasse sur plateau d'on n'est pas
couché il faut voir le contexte je
venais de sortir un livre qui a été
difficile à écrire après les attentats
pour défendre charlie hebdo et je me
retrouve dans ce cirque médiatique qui
est l'émission on n'est pas couché qui a
par ailleurs plein d'autres qualités
mais là j'étais face à aymeric caron qui
cherchait absolument justement le clash
le buzz
en fait il voulait se faire plaisir en
essayant de de se payer ma tête parce
que j'ai la réputation d'être plutôt
doué en débat et du coup ils avaient
envie d'avoir son trophée et moi j'avais
n'était pas d'humeur j'avoue que j'étais
pas venu pour ça
j'étais venu pour défendre ce livre que
cette émission est perdu vos nerfs car
les souvent reste une fois en 20 ans
enfin j'ai perdu mes nerfs j'ai dit je
sais plus ce que j'ai dit mais j'en ai
marre d'écouter ce qu'on voit là c'était
pas non plus ça commence comme ans pour
vous l'engagement carolis a commencé à
quel âge je vous dis ça parce que par
exemple gisèle elle a 11 ans c'est une
petite fille elle fait la grève de la
faim et elle exige auprès de ses parents
d'être traité comme ses frères
je pense que moi mon engagement d'après
ma mère qui me l'a rappelé parce que je
m'en souvenais évidemment pas en tout
cas mon premier manifeste c'était à 5
ans quand j'ai annoncé à ma mère que
plus tard je me marierai avec une femme
donc après il a fallu gagner le droit de
se marier avec une femme ça ça a pris
quand même tout même sa douce à chez
vous ça commence à 5 ans on dit une
chose pareille savais pas ce que je
savais que j'étais pas ce que j'ai à 5
ans j'ai compris que j'étais différente
et que et qu'il faudrait se battre
sacrément pour l'imposer mais c'était un
goût à cette époque j'ai un engagement
mais ça pourrait s aurait pu non à ça
crée évidemment je n'ai pas conscience
est ce que je vous disais mais moi j'ai
pas construit s'être engagé j'ai juste
l'impression de vouloir vivre librement
et mais qui je veux et il ya plein de
gens qui essaient de l'interdire donc
j'ai dû me défends qui a rien dans votre
caractère ou dans votre nature qui vous
a amené
à cet engagement c'est pas quelque chose
que vous ressentez vous vous dis non non
il faut que je me batte là dessus non
parce qu'enfin en plus moi j'étais
enfant très très sage et très posé mu
réfléchi j'ai jamais fait de bêtises
petit j'ai commencé à jamais été
révoltée ouais je suis pas révolté
simplement moi j'étais petit chanter la
marseillaise j'ai toujours aimé les
rituels républicain mais je crois
beaucoup au collectif je crois beaucoup
aux institutions je crois tu
profondément démocrates et j'ai jamais
eu cette passion même pour la révolution
qu'on a à 18 ans pas du tout par contre
quand j'ai compris que la promesse
d'égalité et républicaines auxquelles à
laquelle j'ai cru très jeunes avaient
vraiment manqué parfois et que par
exemple je n'avais pas le droit
d'épouser qui je voulais et que j'avais
face à moi des gentils me détester
simplement pour qui j'étais là j'ai dit
non elle a écouté là ça va pas être
possible va falloir corriger deux trois
trucs pour qu'on y croit vraiment à
cette république
donc le fait effectivement que vous
aimiez les femmes ça participe de votre
engagement assez le sait la source de
tous mes engagements c'est la source de
tous vos engagements
c'est étonnant comme ben j'ai pas eu le
choix
ouais j'ai pas eu le choix parce que
pour moi il était impossible de
m'interdire d'aimer qui j'aime et je
voulais pas spécialement je souhaitais
pas l'imposer aux autres je voulais
juste qu'on me laisse être moi mairie à
partir du nom des gens vous
l'interdisent vous en empêche
vous commencez à dire bah écoutez moi je
vais m'intéresser à vous est ce que ça
vous intéresse à moi est ce que ça veut
dire des coûts que juste le fait d'être
une femme
en fait en soi ça porte un engagement en
fait non non pas en soi parce que si on
a décidé d'être une femme traditionnelle
et de finalement trouver que le monde va
bien tel qu'il est pour les femmes pour
les minorités ben non on n'est pas du
tout obligé d'en tirer les conséquences
pour ça que c'est la fram eu la fameuse
phrase de pouvoir c'est ce qu'a dit on
ne naît pas femme on le devient
ça veut dire qu'on choisit nous
considérer qu'être une femme ça veut
dire quelque chose et qu'en gros on
choisit de ne pas accepter le sexisme ou
l'homophobie non ça il faut que choisit
alors j'ai ultravide avoir votre regard
sur un certain nombre de femmes
je les ai choisis j'avoue en me marre en
bien
vous dire honnêtement propose de
découvrir la première fois c'est une
héroïne de mon enfance où vous mettez un
adjectif qui vous vient quand vous voyez
la photo par exemple d'angélique
marquise des anges toi
j'adore enchérit merci les anges à non
mais j'adore pour moi c'est une des
premières héroïnes à la télévision qui
m'inspire parce que avant gillick
marquise des anges les seuls personnages
romanesques qu'on voit à la télé sont
des hommes
les seuls qui voyagent qui ont des
aventures qui équipe se bat qui font
qu'ils ont de l'action c'est que des
hommes angélique c'est la première on se
dit ah tiens les femmes peuvent faire ça
aussi par ailleurs elle est très rock
and roll à l'édition chez qui elle veut
elle couche tout le temps en temps bon
elle se fait pas mal dieu mais aussi
parce qu'ils sont assez réalistes c'est
par rapport à ce qu'elle subit
mais elle vit elle est en vie alors
évidemment vous l'avez déjà citée
j'ai choisi une image de simone de
beauvoir bien entendu elle est
importante définitive incontournable
c'est quoi sinon honnêtement moi c'est
pas simone de beauvoir qui a inspiré mon
finalistes je voulais dit c'est quelque
chose de beaucoup plus instinctif et
vécu mais c'est le cas quasiment tout le
monde en réalité je reconnais simone de
beauvoir d'avoir était importante dans
le fait de défendre un féminisme non
essentialiste et justement ne repose pas
sur cette idée totalement stupide que
c'est nos hormones le fait de donner la
vie qui fait de nous des êtres
particuliers j'y crois pas une seconde
c'est une construction d'avoir cette
conscience delà de la domination
masculine autres femmes qui portent
aussi exactement ce que vous venez de
dire on est loin en tous cas dans
l'image kadaza ya bien que je
honnêtement en dehors de l'image qu'elle
a publiquement que je connais peu je
crois je crois qu'elle est qu'elles
qu'elles n'émettent pas mal en fait dans
son dans ce domaine moi j'aime toujours
les filles s'en sortent d'une façon ou
d'une autre ou que et enfin catherine
deneuve catherine deneuve cesser aussi
c'est à la fois l'éternel féminin et en
même temps ce que j'aime chez elle c'est
que c'est une femme qui a le droit
d'avoir mauvais caractère et du coup
c'est ça qui fait que même quand elle
pousse des coups de gueule qui parfois
sont peuvent avoir l'air d'être un petit
peu dans le sens de l'éternel justement
au fond elle est quand même
révolutionnaire parce qu'elle est là
cette beauté et le droit de pousser des
coups de gueule c'est la liberté sa
totale total total vous militez vous
nous l'avez déjà dit et on le sait pour
le film pour la laïcité pour les droits
des homosexuels vous militez contre
l'intégrisme
comment vous les choisissez vos sujets
alors ça c'est une très bonne question
parce que justement je les choisis pas
en fonction du nombre d'amis que ça va
me rapporter ça vous l'avez bien compris
effectivement si l'on souhaite et
j'essaie de pas tenir compte du nombre
mais heureusement que ça va m'apporter
oui je les choisis en essayant de me
dire je pense que là je peux être utile
c'est je pense que je peux apporter une
démonstration ou mener une enquête ou
tenir un propos qui va éclairer les gens
qui de bonne foi se laisse abuser par
ces propagandes quand je travaille
que ce soit sur ramadan et l'époque sur
marine le pen sur christine boutin sur
les réseaux anti pacs aux autres
j'essaie juste d'aller trouver
l'information qui fait que encore une
fois des gens qui disent ah non ils sont
pas si extrêmes ils sont pas si
intégristes on exagère mais s'ils sont
de bonne foi bondi a quand même j'avais
pas vu vous n'avez pas toujours raison
parfois ya des sujets sur lesquels vous
allez enquêter et puis vous trouvez pas
où vous avez eu tort ça vous est arrivé
alors honnêtement mais c'est pas
je me suis pas souvent souvent trompés
mais il ya une raison à ça c'est que
justement quand je m'aperçois que
peut-être mon a priori était était pas
partez d'une envie mais est contredit
par des faits je pense sincèrement avoir
l'honnêteté d'en tenir compte et du coup
il ya pas mal de confères qui vise mais
comment tu fais pour avoir vu ce qui se
passait exactement avec le printemps
arabe
j'étais des premières à voir que le
printemps arabe sur un mouvement
historique elle dire à la radio j'ai été
une des premières à dire que jeremy
corbyn ne ferait perdre la gauche
anglaise pendant dix ans alors que tout
le monde disait que c'était fantastique
et personne n'a parlé de ses positions
controversées qui sont maintenant dans
le débat et qu'ils viennent de le faire
perdre 10 actuellement comme je l'avais
dit j'étais une des seules en france à
dire que trump sont réélus six mois
avant l'élection a expliqué que les
russes s'en réjouir et et sortirait
d'ailleurs le linceul de hillary clinton
allègrement enfin je veux dire sur plein
de sujets j'ai eu raison avant tout le
monde et j'en ai pris plein la figure
avant tout le monde et c'est pas un don
de voyance c'est simplement que
justement
j'essaie d'enquêté et de regarder les
choses du point de vue de la trajectoire
qu'est-ce que s'est donné 10 et j'essaie
de travailler pas simplement à partir
des gens qui pensent comme moi mais je
travaille sur les gens qui pensent pas
comme moi au dos et je sue et je
respecte assez la cohérence de leur
idéologie
pour comprendre que des gens qui
puissent y adhérer on est quand même
dans une époque
en tout cas pour moi moi je sais pas
quand vous faites et je veux bien savoir
ultra compliqué il faut pas discriminer
faut pas faire l'amalgamé faut pas être
islamophobe faut avoir le droit de
militer pour que les femmes puissent
porter le voile faut avoir le droit de
militer pour interdire le voile bon bref
moi je
c'est compliqué de penser je trouve
c'est très difficile de penser de faim
c'est très courageux de penser
aujourd'hui penser et parler aujourd'hui
c'est extrêmement courageux on est dans
un monde où le moindre propos que vous
allez tenir va être décontextualisés
déformé repris en boucle
analyse et elle le sait ce que vous
faites aux vous prenez vous regarder à
la loupe vous décortiquez c'est
exactement ce que vous mais moi je le
fais dans son contexte justement
kankankan un prédicateur comme tariq
ramadan pas sur les plateaux télé et
abuse tout le monde et la plupart des
journalistes
je vais pas me contenter de ce qu'il dit
sur un plateau de télé rapidement je
vais aller lire tous ces livres je vais
ôter toutes ses interviews je vais
l'écouter les sermons qu'il donne dans
des réseaux qui ne sont pas écoutés les
réseaux de son public
religieux et je vais comparer tout ça et
je vais tout remettre dans le contexte
c'est à dire quels sont les
sous-entendus quelles sont les
références théologiques idéologique et
là ça va devenir quelque chose qui le
donnent une trajectoire qui me
permettent pas me tromper a dit
aujourd'hui sa caroline dans un moment
où on tweet sur un star où on est sur
deux trois écrans au même moment mais
c'est là où j'ai essayé d'apporter
peut-être de trouver une utilité par
rapport à certains confrères c'est à
dire que je ne suis pas dans un journal
j'ai une chronique dans marianne toutes
les semaines mais quand je fais un livre
j'ai tout le temps oui pour
contextualiser je prends ce temps quand
chez mon livre sur marine le pen
j'ai plein de confrères qui sont séduits
par sa nouvelle tendance à elle sa façon
de présenter un regard et un visage
avenant du front national moi je vais
prendre tout le temps d'aller retrouver
toutes les casseroles tout ce qui tout
ce qu'elles ne montrent pas je produis
un livre ensuite des confrères qui sont
dans la dans le feu de l'actualité ce
qui n'est pas mon cas
oui peuvent s'en saisir pour approfondir
leurs papiers donc c'est ce que vous
vous adressez pas forcément au grand
public
si les deux après moi j'essaie de
vulgariser de leur pédagogie clair le
souci que j'ai depuis quelques années
c'est pour ça que passer à la fiction
c'est qu'entre les confrères qui vous en
veulent parce qu'ils n'ont pas vu ce que
vous avez vu et qui au lieu de reprendre
votre boulot ce que je suis pour moi
qu'on puisse qu'il y en a qui vous pompe
qui vous cite pas c'est pas un problème
mais ce que j'aime pas c'est qu'en plus
ils vous attaque parce qu ils vous
reprochent au fond d'eux d'avoir
peut-être un peu mieux fait leur travail
et d mais moi je pense que c'est une
chaîne d'information ceux qui ont tout
faire des essais à ce canton l'actualité
c'est pas un prof ça veut dire et on va
y revenir sur la fiction que vous n'avez
pas le sentiment d'avoir réussi avec vos
livres avec vos reportages avec vos
chroniques avec vos engagements à faire
changer les choses sinon je suggère par
exemple à mais sur toutes les alertes
que j'ai lancé j'ai fini par être
entendu
j'ai aucun regret j'ai aucune amertume
au contraire je pense que j'ai vécu des
choses extraordinaires avec la société
quoi par exemple je pense qu'en europe
on serait pas dans le même climat
si en france tout particulièrement si on
n'avait pas réussi à sauver l'idée qu'il
existait une gauche charlie qui peut à
la fois être un antidote à la tentation
racistes et nationalistes actuelle et à
la tentation du déni et de l'aveuglément
envers l'islamisme
je vais beaucoup aux états unis en ce
moment je peux vous dire que cette
gauche et n'existe pas là bas on l'a
sauvé en europe
et je croyais avoir contribué à mon
petit niveau et je suis très heureuse de
sa si je passe à la fiction c'est pas
parce que j'ai l'impression d'avoir
échoué c'est parce que d'abord j'ai
envie de me faire plaisir
aussi j'ai envie de me protéger comme ça
quand au bout d'un moment on pouvait pas
tout le temps vous sacrifier tout le
temps aller au combat tout le temps les
prendre des coups et j'ai l'impression
quand même que je serai plus audible de
certains jeunes à qui j'ai envie de
parler avec qui j'ai envie de partager
bah c'est plus facile d'aller dans une
salle de cinéma de regarder un film que
de se taper avec un peu austère a
effectué l
exactement je pense que ça on peut pas
se contenter d'écrire des livres si
vraiment on veut changer le monde
je crois que ça n'arrive pas y renoncer
il faut aussi aller sur le terrain
artistique
j'en ai besoin et en plus c'est utile
donc à l'ordre infirmier film était
consacrée à des femmes bien entendu à
des guerrières avec combattante vous
pourriez prendre les armes vous j'ai
fait un film pour pas pour pas prendre
les armes parce que je les ai ressenti
cette envie bien sûr après les attentats
pendants le nice est pas tellement le
niveau de violence que vous voyez face à
vous c'est pas le fait d'être sous
protection policière pendant un temps ce
n'est pas le fait d'avoir les menaces
depuis des années c'est que face à la
bêtise l aveuglement aux réflexes
moutonniers et
au nombre d'autruche qui moule qui vous
qui vend plus et c'est de vous faire
taire un moment donné vous avez envie de
simplicité et la simplicité dans ce
combat dans cette guerre elle était
clairement sur le front elle était quand
des femmes kurdes sont allés nous
défendre face à ceux qui voulaient me
tuer donc moi j'avais besoin d'aller sur
le front j'avais besoin de les voir
j'avais besoin les soutenir et j'ai fait
une une rencontre avec un groupe de la
guérilla kurde dans les montagnes de
sinjar là où il ya eu lieu le génocide
et zi et j'ai eu le plus beau compliment
qu'on puisse me faire puisque la la
commandante on a passé l'après-midi à
parler avec un traducteur yézidie et
elle m'a dit mais toi tu mènes on est
épaté pas cinéaste n'est pas journaliste
et une combattante ça se voit jeudi et
écoute c'est un très beau compliment
venant d'une commandante j'en suis très
flatté mais je sais pas tiré à la
kalachnikov
j'ai pas envie d'apprendre par contre tu
peux faire un film pour vous contre eux
qui vous auriez prises les armes quand
je rentre je les aurai comptes suisses
avaient tiré oui mais je suis plus utile
autrement plus utile autrement les
homophobes les intégristes les
défenseurs d'une autre laïcité des
journalistes parfois des associatives
des intellectuels vous réussissiez à
cristalliser un certain nombre de gens
on va dire que contre vous est-ce que
c'est parfois pour aussi mais ça n'est
pas parfois franchement plus en allemand
mais certainement mais il ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont quand même acerbe et
qu'ils sont et je me dis quelle que soit
la raison pour certains ils ont raison
pour d'autres ils ont tort ça doit être
lourd parfois
alors d'abord non c'est important à
savoir si l'on fait son coup parce que
ça c'est une question de perception
aussi on peut ne pas être d'accord avec
vous tant pis oui mais il ya ça est
d'accord avec moi
me contredire ça c'est pas un sou ça n'a
jamais été là on parle de gens qui sont
super énervés qui sont surexcités il y
en a ils écrivent il y en a qui ont
écrit quarante papier un journal politis
quoi que je fasse depuis 20 ans il écrit
des papiers orduriers contre moi de
façon incroyable et je les ai connus ce
garçon il ya 20 ans simplement
politicien c'est un journal de
compagnonnage de tariq ramadan
donc forcément ils m'en veulent je
comprends c'est bon ou pas c'est pénible
c'est fini de me répondre sur le fond
quand ça vient des réseaux pro islamiste
d'extrême droite qu'on sait attendu
c'est normal je suis allé moi-même
débusquer que je suis allé à être direct
qui j'ai franchement un peu pourri la
vie je les accepte et je le comprends
ce qui m'ennuie c'est que des gens ne
fassent pas la perdre et choisi ne
comprennent pas que je paye ça de la
part des groupes que j'ai été chatouillé
et que donc c'est normal que voilà il
aboie sur moi depuis des années sur
internet ce qui est plus pénible et ce
qui est plus douloureux vraiment c'est
quand des gens qui sont que je défends
ma raison des militants homos des
militantes féministes
ouais urnes avec la meute d'homophobe de
ces listes est d'intégrer ce que j'ai
essayé de le contrer on fait ça c'est
oui ça c'est douloureux franchement
c'est pénible
comment vous faites dans ces cas là bas
je fais autre chose je fais des films à
l'elysée d'être heureuse quand on se bat
on peut se dire qu'on se bat pour qu'on
se bat contre vous vous êtes pour ou
contre
je crois sincèrement je me bats plus tôt
contre mais je les assume
c'est à dire que j'ai beaucoup plus dur
que de se battre pour je sais pas je ne
sais pas parce que justement
contrairement à l'image que je donne je
n'ai pas d'idée arrêtée sur le court
j'ai joué le jeu voyez sur les questions
économiques et sociales souvent on me
reproche de la has et intervenir mais
c'est parce que j'ai pas d'idée
définitive moi j'ai besoin d'écouter les
gens j'ai besoin d'avoir le tour de
toutes les données pour avoir une idée
je suis pas idéologue dans ce domaine je
suis plutôt pour l'état providence j'ai
envie que l'état s'occupe du social soit
au service des plus faibles ça c'est une
certitude
après comment on est plus efficace là
dessus je veux bien me remettre en
question à chaque dossier est bon quand
pour et je n'ai pas d'idée arrêtée en
réalité ce que je sais c'est qu'il ya
des gens qui sont contre la démocratie
c'est pour ça que j'ai plutôt travailler
sur des apprentis totalitaire que sur
des gens avec qui j'ai eu des désaccords
mineurs il ya des gens qui sont haineux
il ya des gens qui veulent nous monter
les uns contre les autres
et je crois que je peux essayer de les
arrêter à mon niveau à ma modeste
contribution en tout cas j'essaie voilà
le combat que vous aimeriez gagner le
combat que j'aimerais gagner c'est
d'abord j'aimerais vraiment que l'europe
échappe à la chapelle à l'avalanche de
gouvernement d'extrême droite qui nous
menacent ça fait 20 ans que je me bats
pour ça ça fait 20 ans que je me bats
pour contrer la vague le mans sur
l'islamisme parce que je pense que la
vague le mans sur l'islamisme fait
monter l'extrême droite et que toutes
les leçons de morale que je reçois de
ceux qui amalgame et position avec des
positions islamophobes des positions
haineuse je pense que c'est eux le
danger c'est eux qui les font monter je
connais par coeur les raisons qui
poussent les gens à voter pour l'extrême
droite
je crois que s'il existe un camp
républicain de droite ou de gauche mais
des gens sensés équilibré qui ne veulent
pas tomber dans la m
mais qui ne veulent pas accepter le déni
je pense qu'on peut vraiment s'en sortir
on va s'en sortir
celle toute dernière question et si
c'était à refaire je ferais tout pareil
tout pareil je referais tout pareil je
vais peut-être me protégerait un peu
plus de temps en temps voilà j'ai géré
un petit peu moins en moins de soldats
me mettre toujours en première ligne
mais honnêtement je sais que les tout ça
a servi à quelque chose
c'est quand même c'est quelque chose qui
nourrit en fait de se battre ça ne se
nourrit pas d'abord tentons quand on
n'aime pas le monde autrement on peut
pas le changer exactement comme on veut
mais au moins on sait qu'on essaie de
participer au fait qui ressemble un peu
au monde qu'on aime merci karl et merci
[Musique]
tous